do you ever wonder why we're surrounded
with things that help us do everything
faster and faster and faster communicate
faster but also work faster Bank faster
travel faster find a date faster cook
faster clean faster and do all of it all
at the same time how do you feel about
cramming even more into every waking
hour well to my generation of Americans
speed feels like a birthright sometimes
I think our minimum speed is Mach 3
anything less and we fear losing our
competitive edge but even my generation
is starting to question whether were the
Masters of speed or if speed is
mastering us I'm an anthropologist at
the RAND Corporation and while many
anthropologists study ancient cultures I
focus on modern-day cultures and how
we're adapting to all of this change
happening in the world recently I teamed
up with an engineer say futon day to
study speed we were interested both in
how people are adapting to this age of
acceleration and its security and policy
implications what could our world look
like in 25 years if the current pace of
change keeps accelerating what would it
mean for transportation or learning
communication manufacturing weaponry or
even natural selection will a faster
future make us more secure and
productive or will it make us more
vulnerable in our research people
accepted acceleration as inevitable both
the thrills and the lack of control they
fear that if they were to slow down they
might run the risk of becoming obsolete
they say they'd rather burn out than
rust out yet at the same time they
worried that speed could erode their
cultural traditions and their sense of
home but even people who are winning at
the speedgame admit to feeling a little
uneasy
see they see acceleration as widening
the gap between the haves the
jet-setters who are buzzing around and
have-nots who are left in the digital
dust yes we have good reason to forecast
that the future will be faster but what
I've come to realize is that speed is
paradoxical and like all good paradoxes
it teaches us about the human experience
as absurd and complex as it is the first
paradox is that we love speed and we're
thrilled by its intensity but our
prehistoric brains aren't really built
for it so we invent roller coasters and
racecars and supersonic planes but we
get whiplash carsick jet-lagged we
didn't evolve to multitask rather we
evolved to do one thing with incredible
focus like hunt not necessarily with
great speed but with endurance for great
distance but now there's a widening gap
between our biology and our lifestyles a
mismatch between what our bodies are
built for and what we're making them do
it's a phenomenon my mentors have called
stone Agers in the fast lane a second
paradox of speed is that it can be
measured objectively right miles per
hour gigabytes per second but how speed
feels and whether we like it is highly
subjective so we can document that the
pace at which we are adopting new
technologies is increasing for example
it took 85 years
from the introduction of the telephone
to when the majority of Americans had
phones at home in contrast it only took
13 years for most of us to have
smartphones and how people act and react
to speed varies by culture and among
different people within the same culture
interactions that could be seen as
pleasantly brisk and convenient in some
cultures could be seen as horribly rude
another's I mean you wouldn't go asking
for a to-go cup at a Japanese tea
ceremony so you could jet off to your
next tourist stop would you
a third paradox is that speed begets
speed the faster I respond the more
responses I get the faster I have to
respond again having more communication
and information at our fingertips at any
given moment was supposed to make
decision-making easier and more rational
but that doesn't really seem to be
happening here's just one more paradox
if all of these faster technologies are
supposed to free us from drudgery why do
we all feel so pressed for time why are
we crashing our cars and record numbers
because we think we have to answer that
text right away shouldn't life in the
fast lane feel a little more fun and a
little less anxious German speakers even
have a word for this aisle con kite in
English that's hurry sickness when we
have to make fast decisions autopilot
brain kicks in and we rely on our
learned behaviors our reflexes our
cognitive biases to help us perceive and
respond quickly sometimes that saves our
lives right fight-or-flight but
sometimes it leads us astray in the long
run often times when our society has
major failures they're not technological
failures they're failures that happened
when we made decisions too quickly on
autopilot we didn't do the creative or
critical thinking required to connect
the dots or weed out false information
or make sense of complexity that kind of
thinking can't be done fast that's slow
thinking to psychologists Daniel
Kahneman and Amos Tversky started
pointing this out back in 1974 and we're
still struggling to do something with
their insights but all of modern history
can be thought of as one spurt of
acceleration after another it's as if we
think if we just speed up enough we can
outrun our problems but we never do we
know this in our own lives and
policymakers know it too so now we're
turning to artificial intelligence
to help us make faster and smarter
decisions to process this ever-expanding
universe of data but machines crunching
data are no substitute for critical and
sustained thinking by humans whose Stone
Age brains need a little time to let
their impulses subside to slow the mind
and let the thoughts flow if you're
starting to think that we should just
hit the brakes that won't always be the
right solution we all know that a train
that's going too fast around a bend can
derail but Saifu the engineer taught me
that a train that's going too slowly
around a bend can also derail so
managing this spurt of acceleration
starts with the understanding that we
have more control over speed than we
think we do individually and as a
society sometimes we'll need to engineer
ourselves to go faster we'll want to
solve gridlock speed up disaster relief
for hurricane victims or use 3d printing
to produce what we need on the spot just
when we need it sometimes though we'll
want to make our surroundings feel
slower to engineer the crash out of the
speedy experience and it's okay not to
be stimulated all the time it's good for
adults and for kids
maybe it's boring but it gives us time
to reflect slow time is not wasted time
and we need to reconsider what it means
to save time culture and rituals around
the world build in slowness because
slowness helps us reinforce our shared
values and connect and connection is a
critical part of being human we need to
master speed and that means thinking
carefully about the trade-offs of any
given technology will it help you
reclaim time that you can use to express
your humanity will give you hurry
sickness will give other people hurry
sickness if you're lucky enough to
decide the pace that you want to travel
through life that's a privilege use it
you might decide that you need both to
speed up and to create slow time time to
reflect to percolate at your own pace
time to listen to empathize to rest your
mind to linger at the dinner table so as
we zoom into the future let's consider
setting the technologies of speed the
purpose of speed and our expectations of
speed to a more human pace thank you